bachelor Paradise is being reshaped
right now the season is starting over
after the controversy that involves
Corinne and Mario and we now know that
at least one of those two will not be
returning suffering from anxiety seeing
a therapist damaged because he'll always
be linked to the scandal those are the
alleged reasons why de Mario will not
return to paradise
as for Corinne well there's a report
that claims she hasn't even been asked
back and there's a chance she won't be
seen on The Bachelor of franchise ever
again so what exactly does it take to be
a Paradise contestant well usually
you've got to be willing to basically
sign your life away a producer here at a
tea has seen a 27 page contract used by
the franchise and contestants actually
agree to let producers quote change add
to edit or reprocess anything they say
and do it Contessa has also acknowledged
producers don't encourage intimate or
sexual contact and it's okay if the
series exposes them to quote public
ridicule humiliation or condemnation I
have the it factor that guys really like
now how much of reality TV is actually
real well this scene where Corinne is
censored and it looks as if she's naked
under that trenchcoat well she had
underwear on
this scene when Juan Pablo looks as if
he had sex in the ocean nothing happened
and here where it looks as if contestant
Clare lost it and was actually talking
to a raccoon she was actually talking to
a producer they just edited that out I
don't want that and that creates drama I
don't want
[Music]